staying strong Christina Applegate who
just revealed there were warning signs
to her Ms diagnosis I started thinking
about the last four years and I had very
small symptoms we were on set and I'd go
like oh I think I'm tired you know so it
presented itself like a few years ago
until it just not as bad as it it did
Christina tells Kelly Clarkson her role
on dead to me helped her process it all
I could fall apart in a scene and it was
like my soul actually falling apart and
it was cathartic Kelly also had a huge
surprise for Christina who's a below
deck Super Fan I want to encourage you
to stay strong I literally
guys I love him so much also feeling the
love the today shows Al Roker who is
home after being released from the
hospital today Mr Roker is off uh he
continues to recover Al who had a big
grin on his face also shared photos with
his wife and daughter he's been off the
air for five weeks now this morning the
weather anchor posted this pic from
inside his hospital room and wrote when
your spirit sags a bit you get to see
that and recharge Al was readmitted to
the hospital the day after Thanksgiving
for blood clots in his leg and lungs TJ
remains in hiding as multiple sources
tell ET that ABC is conducting an
internal review to see if TJ and Amy
violated any company policies
specifically the company's morality
Clause we're fill it in for TJ Holmes
and Amy Robuck Amy and TJ remained
sidelined today and have been off the
anchor desk for the fourth day in a row
[Music]